encuentra el valor que falta para que la
siguiente tabla represente una ecuación
lineal veamos que tenemos en la tabla
cuando x tiene el valor de 1 y es igual
a 3 medios cuando de x tiene el valor de
2 y es igual a 3 que está pasando aquí
x va de 1 a 2 incrementando su valor en
y al mismo tiempo y va de tres medios a
33 medios es 1.5 1.5 para 3 es igual a
1.5 por lo tanto y está incrementando 3
medios
se puede decir que 3 es igual a 6 medios
por lo que 6 medios menos 3 medios nos
da 3 medios
muy bien ahora vamos en x de 2 a 3 x
vuelve a incrementar en 1 que está
pasando con ye yé vamos de 3 a 9 medios
anteriormente dijimos que 3 es igual a 6
medios por lo que vamos de 6 medios a 9
medios así que una vez más ya está
incrementando en tres medios
para que esta tabla pueda representar
una ecuación lineal o una relación
lineal cada vez que x incremente en 1
que deberá incrementar en 3 medios
si x incrementa en 2 como aquí de 1 a 3
entonces ya debe incrementar dos veces
tres medios como aquí que vamos de tres
medios a nueve medios
ahora qué pasa con este valor de la
tabla
aquí x va de 3 a 8 entonces x está
incrementando en 5
así que si x incrementa en 5 ya deberá
incrementar cinco veces tres medios
cinco veces tres medios es igual a 5 por
3 15 medios esto es la cantidad que debe
incrementar y si se parte desde 9 medios
y debe incrementar 15 medios entonces
tenemos 9 15 es igual a 24 medios que
esto es igual a 12
12 es el valor que faltaba que
encontráramos para que esta tabla pueda
representar una ecuación lineal y
terminamos